- [Pablo] Perfect.
So let's get started.
So network operations at scale
has three major challenges,
manual processes that don't scale,
inconsistent deployments
that create security risks,
and validation that happens too late.
In the session today,
we're going to try to
solve these challenges,
applying the same principles
majority of your developer teams
or of your developers are already doing
in your own teams,
which is automation testing
and policy-driven deployment.
Welcome, everybody.
This is NET323,
networks at scale and how
to automate operations.
My name is Pablo Sanchez.
I'm a senior network specialist
solutions architect at AWS.
And with me I have Claudia.
- [Claudia] Hi, everyone.
I'm Claudia Izquierdo.
I'm a senior solutions
architect here at AWS.
- [Pablo] Perfect. So
what's the agenda today?
Which one of you knows
what a code talk is?
Raise your hand.
So not so many people.
Okay, perfect.
So the agenda today is going to be
intensive in coding solutions.
So we will try to be here
speaking less amount of time
and just more interacting with
you while we build something.
But first of all we wanted
to kind of expand on these
scaling challenges in AWS networking.
What are the best practices
for these automated network operations
that we have seen in customers?
We will explain briefly the use
case that we're going to use
as an example today.
And then, of course, time to code,
and then a little bit of
takeaways for the session.
We're going to be talking
about all of the things,
so which things we want you to
take after the session today.
So about these challenges.
So let me start kind of painting a picture
that maybe the majority
of you kind of can relate.
So a company starts small,
small number of VPCs,
just connect between them,
a couple of accounts,
and that it's easy to get full control,
to know exactly how things connect,
what's the security of this application,
and of course, like, make sure
that everything's documented
and it's working perfectly.
But then growth happens.
New VPCs come in, new
accounts, mergers can happen,
and then suddenly it's
not a natural growth.
It can be exponential.
And those tight controls
or those controls initially
for these small environments
can be called a bottleneck
for specific teams.
Usually cloud network networking teams
are not that big teams in comparison
to the amount of resources
that you guys need to manage.
And then applications team,
they're asking them to be agile,
but then they need to start waiting time
to get some approvals and
to get some routes done
or some specific security
controls in place.
And of course, these teams,
because they want to be agile, they are,
well, let's say that
they're well-intentioned,
hopefully a majority of the time, yes.
They open a port,
they open a security group
a little bit more open
that we would like to have to get
that connectivity happening.
And now we have configuration drifts
and now we have configuration
that we don't know what's
happening with them.
And of course, like, when
we need to troubleshoot
or when we need to know
exactly what's happening
with our environment,
we're not really sure on what's happening.
So kind of that's what we see that
when we grow we get
these three main things,
this consistency and governance issues,
manual configuration bottlenecks,
and especially change management.
We always tell, like, the
cloud allows you to be agile,
but then, of course,
usually we think, like,
the network is something fixed,
and that shouldn't be like that.
The cloud network should also
allow for change management
without adding extra complexity into that.
- [Claudia] So to face
these three challenges
that Pablo just mentioned,
we are starting to first, one,
adopt the to work with a
multi-account environment,
and this multi-account environment
also comes with guardrails.
So working with guardrails helps you
to focus on permission
control for the security
of your architecture instead
of only networking blocking.
And with this you can improve
how to manage the security
of your architecture
and with that your network in AWS
and also to make this easier for everyone.
And second is to use
managed AWS network services
that we have here at AWS,
but more specifically the
service to build global networks.
So like Pablo mentioned,
the task for all these network engineers
like creating Amazon VPCs,
creating AWS site-to-site VPN,
creating a routing table,
adding routes, deleting these routes,
all of these different
tasks can be optimized
and help all these network engineers
working with these global networks.
And then go serverless.
Use the different serverless services
that we have at AWS so you can deploy
and automate these many different tasks
that not only the network
engineers has to do,
but also the many requests
that may be having
for the many different
users that are asking
for help from these network engineers.
So how does this look at AWS?
First one, to start
using AWS Organizations.
AWS Organization is the
service that we have at AWS
where you can deploy
multi-accounts
environments, architectures,
and also app guardrails
which are named service control policies.
So first start with AWS Organizations.
That then work with AWS Cloud WAN.
AWS Cloud WAN, it's a service
to build global networks,
but not only building global networks,
to build global networks
with policy as code.
So in this session you're going to learn
how to build these policies.
So the idea here is to
know a little bit more
about AWS Cloud WAN
and AWS Step Functions.
Step Functions is going to help you
to automate the different steps
that are required to build the things
that the networking engineers need help,
but orchestrating those
different steps that are required
for this to happen
and to help everyone in everything.
- [Pablo] Perfect.
So what's the use case we're going to try
to use today to show you
these best practices?
So basically we have an environment
where the IP address management
we want to be controlled by VPC IPAM.
We want to make sure that
teams don't create VPCs
with IPs are not into the IPAM portal
that we are going to provide to them.
We need traffic segmentation.
The logic we're using
today is we want to have
a routing domain per environment,
dev, prod, whatever routing
environment we have,
we are going to keep it simple for today,
but we want to have that
traffic segmentation
also in our network.
We want to have traffic inspection.
We want to make sure that
everything is inspected
between routing domains
and anything that goes
out to the internet.
And of course, it needs to be
low in operational overhead
because we only have two engineers,
the two people that you see
right now here talking to you
only managing all that network at scale.
So what we have already built
and then I'll go to what we
are going to be building today.
So this is the organizations we have.
We're keeping it simple
but definitely think of more
than one organizational unit.
But we have three accounts.
We have the account that is going to be
managing AWS Organizations, one account,
networking accounting in the
networking organizational unit,
and the spoke account in
the dev organizational unit.
In the networking account,
we have defined Amazon VPC
IPAM with a root pool 10/8,
and then to each one of the
regions we are defining a pool
for the dev environment
that we are sharing using AWS
Resource Access Manager, RAM,
with that specific spoke account.
So the spoke account can
only use the IPAM pools
we are sharing.
On the network level, AWS Cloud WAN,
we have a initial version of the network
and we're going to be building more
during the session today.
We have a hybrid segment
and a dev segment.
I think we also have a prod segment.
So we have, like, some
segmentation already created
and we have, for the ones that don't know,
we have service insertion.
We will explain later in a moment.
But that's our way in Cloud
WAN to automate the creation
of inspection by just
simply telling the service,
hey, I want to inspect these
two or these two segments
or between a segment
or things outside of the, to the internet.
But we have already created
that inspection segment,
which is called a network function group,
and our three inspection VPCs
with AWS Network Firewall
already created them.
So we are just going to be
creating the inspection itself.
And of course, AWS Cloud
WAN is created by AWS,
is shared using Resource Access Manager
with the rest of the accounts.
- [Claudia] But Pablo, don't
you think that everyone is here
to learn a little bit of coding?
- [Pablo] Yeah, so we
are going to be coding.
I think we took 10 minutes,
which is exactly the time
we were thinking about.
So let's go into with the
different requirements.
Let's go with the first requirement,
which is VPC IPAM as only
IP allocation source.
So what are we going to do?
First, we're going to
show that by default,
I can create noncompliant VPCs
just to show that how, that by default,
yes, someone can create something
outside of the VPC IPAM.
Once we do that,
what we're going to do is
create a service control policy
that only allows creation
of VPCs with the IPAM pools
shared with the account.
We're going to do the same creation
and we're going to get it denied
and afterwards we're going
to be starting creating
the different VPCs.
So let me change to the demo.
Let's go for it.
- [Claudia] Thanks, Pablo.
So I'll be walking around here,
so if you have questions
please, let me know.
Remember this is an interactive session,
so the idea is to hear from you too.
So Pablo, can I just
know what are you coding,
what type of coding it is,
why are you using Kiro?
- [Pablo] Yes, so, well, first of all,
I'm using Kiro, if you don't know,
it's our IDE that also allows
us to use GenAI agents.
We're not going to be doing
the help of AI agents today.
It's going to be Pablo AI.
But then what I'm using
is VPC Terraform module
that we're going to be coding
everything today in Terraform,
a VPC module created by us
that are maintained by us,
by the networking team
in in AWS just to create
where I'm going to start
creating that non-compliant VPC
and then I'm going to move to put the SCP
in AWS Organizations.
- [Claudia] Thank you, Pablo.
So the idea in here is that
we are just getting started.
This is IPAM.
IPAM is, as Pablo mentioned,
is trying to stop someone
to deploying IP address
that is not allowed.
And why it's not allowed,
because Pablo and I as
the networking architects
and engineers decided that that's the pool
that everyone has to use
or it's divided by the different segments
that it's based on the
best practices that he
and I just decide.
So the idea here is to work with IPAM
to use that pool that Pablo and I decide,
but service contrast policy
from AWS Organization,
it's going to help us
so no one is going to deploy a network
that it's not allowed.
So back to you, Pablo.
- [Pablo] Yeah, so basically right now
I'm creating that VPC,
so I'm coming here, I think
I'm creating North Virginia.
So basically now, I guess
you see now better, right?
- [Claudia] Mm-hmm.
- [Pablo] So now we have that VPC
that is not compliant at all
because we are going to be using the 10/8
and we have the 172 range.
So now I'm going to add AWS, the SCP,
to block that specific action to happen.
Let me start by destroying this
and then I'll move to the
part of the code for AWS.
And yes, and then I'll remove this.
Perfect.
So if I move to my organization's folder,
I already have defined the SCP
and the only thing I'm going to do is
going to create the resources
to deploy in my organization's account.
Basically what I'm doing is
denying any creation of a VPC
and also association of
a secondary CIDR block.
I don't want anyone cheating
after they created the
VPC with the IPAM pool.
So denying these two
actions if there's no IPv4
IPAM pool true.
And also because we're
controlling which IPAM pool
we're providing to the dev account,
we're controlling that
is the specific IPAM pool
that they can build.
So I'll create the two
resources right now.
- [Claudia] Thank you, Pablo.
So who from the audience
is working with IPAM?
Okay, and who is working
with AWS Cloud WAN?
Great, I love that.
So the thing in here is
to let that only Pablo
and I as the network specialist to decide
what IP address can be used
by many of the other part of our team,
because, you know, /24, it's
not for all the Amazon VPCs
and for all the subnets.
So if anyone has a question,
please raise your hand
and I will reach to you to
see what question do you have.
So Pablo, back to you.
- [Pablo] Yeah, I'm still finishing, so...
- [Claudia] Okay.
- [Pablo] I don't think I can type
and speak at the same time.
- [Claudia] Don't worry.
- [Miguel] So my question
is how can you share,
maybe you need to RAM
share a specific segment
to a specific account.
- [Claudia] Okay.
- [Miguel] So I wanna know, for example,
if I have a situation where I
dynamically create accounts,
I wanna make sure that specific siders
or segments go to specific accounts.
- [Claudia] Okay, so the
question that, what's your name?
- [Miguel] Miguel.
- [Claudia] Miguel just
ask is how can you make
that an IP address to be attached
or go with a specific
segment like, for example,
dev or production?
Pablo, have you done that before?
- [Pablo] Yeah. Give me a moment.
I'm just troubleshooting.
- [Claudia] Don't worry.
(audience member speaking off mic)
- [Pablo] Ah, yeah, thank you very much.
Definitely I needed an AI for this.
So what was exactly the question?
- [Claudia] How can you make an IP address
to go for a specific segment,
like this is for dev, this is for prod,
and things like that?
- [Pablo] So you need
to apply that logic more
the way you share the
IPAM pools currently.
So you create your IPAM pools
and then, like, you do, like,
when you are doing your
infrastructure as code,
when you do RAM to a specific OU
where it's dev or a test or production.
- [Miguel] But in that case (indistinct)
accounts be dynamically created?
- [Pablo] Mm-hmm.
- [Miguel] I'll have to
have some management.
- [Pablo] Yeah, okay.
So that majority of
customers use control tower
that you can use for CloudFormation
or for Terraform where you can do your...
You can do your account factory,
which you can say, hey,
if this account is dev
then this is the IPAM pool,
and then, of course,
this is your Cloud WAN
or Transit Gateway.
You do that when you create that account,
you create your blueprint,
and then when you do that dynamically,
you just provide those
kind of shared services
in the beginning.
- [Miguel] Would you need
to have a specific account
to run the tower from?
- [Pablo] I think yes.
And I'm not sure,
but definitely yes, you
will need one account
that is the one managing
the account factory.
- [Claudia] Yes.
- [Pablo] And then pushing
to the rest of the accounts.
- [Claudia] Yes, best practices,
it should be one main
account to push everything
from the other accounts
in AWS Organization
and in AWS Control Tower.
Mm-hmm. Yeah.
- [Pablo] Perfect.
So I already have the
service control policy.
You can see here I have
the same JSON I shared you
but now created with our
target or dev account.
So I think I removed that.
Let me see if I can put it back.
Yeah, so now I'm going
to try to create it again
and see that now I want...
I shouldn't be able to
create that specific VPC.
- [Claudia] Mm-hmm.
So Pablo, we have another question.
Why are we using Terraform
and not CloudFormation?
- [Pablo] Hmm, that's a personal decision.
It's just, like, for me it's more native
to write Terraform than CloudFormation.
But that's on me.
(audience member speaking off mic)
Yeah, yeah, all the resources-
- [Audience Member] Libraries
that were created there.
- [Pablo] Yeah, yeah, all the resources
that we are creating today,
they're available in CloudFormation.
Also if you use CDK,
we have layer two constructs for...
Layer three also for these
AWS networking services.
Yeah, yeah.
So I think I did the clear,
but now if I do the apply,
I should get deny on the
service control policy.
So now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to start typing
our proper VPC configuration
with the VPC IPAM pool configure.
- [Claudia] What's the question?
- [Audience Member] Is it
possible to write the SCP policy
without mentioning the IPAM pool?
So basically just mention (indistinct).
So as long as your VPC
gets assigned (indistinct) range.
- [Claudia] So, like, hard code the IP?
- [Audience Member] Yeah.
- [Claudia] Oh, okay.
So the question in here is
that if we can not use IPAM
and go to hard code the IP
addresses in the coding per se.
So it's possible,
but in here, like, the thing is that
with IPAM you are not, like, hard coding.
You're letting to IPAM
to take advantage of...
IPAM, it's not only to,
like, give you IP addresses.
It's going to help you to keep
control of your IP addresses.
So for example, if you
are close to not having
enough IP addresses pretty soon,
it will let you know.
Like, if you are not going to
have enough IP addresses soon.
And also it helps you, as Pablo just say,
to, like, have a design
and how you want to
distribute your IP addresses.
So I think that it helps more to have IPAM
so you can more than just, like,
stop people from not using the IP address
that you would like,
to also have control
and monitoring the
addresses, the IP addresses.
- [Audience Member]
Yeah, but for situations
where you don't use IPAM
or you use a different IPAM.
- Yeah.
- Yeah?
- [Claudia] Yeah. Mm-hmm.
So back to you, Pablo.
- [Pablo] Yeah, so now I have
the version of the VPC created.
So you see that the way we're
doing this is just defining
the VPC IPAM pool, the netmask length.
In that case, it's 24.
Then we also are creating dual stack VPC.
So also with IPv6.
I'm cheating a little bit just
doing a classic copy paste
and change the region.
You see that we're using
North Virginia, Oregon,
and the Spanish region
just to show you, like,
a multi-region solution.
But yeah, and then here what
I'm doing is I have my...
I have some local variable
where I'm obtaining the
IPAM pools from AWS RAM
and just putting in a
local value just to gather,
which is the IPAM ID per
each specific region.
So I won't create the VPCs now.
I will do it everything at the end
so you see how everything
will connect to Cloud WAN
and all the automation it's running.
So now we were able to show,
let me come back to these
slides for a moment,
to show exactly this,
how our first requirement has been met.
So now our VPCs are
compliant in that sense
and they are able to
get the pool from IPAM
and not being hard coded.
So I think we can move to
the second requirement,
which is an easy-to-build global network,
and for that we have AWS Cloud WAN.
But what we need to do there,
we need to do all this,
have inspection between routing domains,
egress inspection, also between regions.
If I have traffic between regions,
I don't want to inspect in both regions.
I only want to inspect in one,
and the one in orange is
the region I want to inspect
for every pair of regions that I have.
And also I want to do something
quite cool in Cloud WAN,
which is I want to automate
how the attachments get associated
to the routing domain automatically.
So basically the logic I want to apply
is that VPC attachments are associated
to their OU routing domain
and anything that is hybrid,
so VPNs, connect attachments,
so to integrate SD-WAN networks
and Direct Connect are
associated to the hybrid segment.
So that's what I'm going to be doing now.
I'm using policy as code in Cloud WAN.
- [Claudia] Perfect.
So something really important
that you are going to see
now that Pablo's going to code that part,
it's that he's going
to work with something
that it's sent to and sent via.
It's, like, the main part of the coding
with AWS Cloud WAN.
Sent to, it's used when you want to know
what the network traffic it's going to end
and sent via is when you
want the network traffic to,
before reaching the end,
to pass in the mid part
before going into the final destination.
So, for example, sent to is like,
hey, it's going to the final destination,
it's on premises or the internet,
and send via is,
hey, but before reaching
the final destination,
go through this part.
And usually as the architecture
that we are working in here,
it's AWS Network Firewall
and inspection Amazon VPC
or a third-party solution for security.
So the, for example,
you have an Amazon VPC
that wants to reach the internet,
and it's like, okay send to internet,
but send via to AWS Network Firewall
or send to Amazon VPC
but send via AWS Network Firewall
so you can deploy the finish
or the end of the network
traffic but also the mid part
before reaching that final destination.
So back to you, Pablo.
- [Pablo] Yeah, so give me a moment
so I don't lose what I'm doing.
So you see that I'm doing something weird
that it's kind of this dynamic block.
So if you have not worked with Terraform,
this is just a way for me
to create dynamically different blocks.
Cloud WAN uses JSON,
but in Terraform to make
it more easy to build,
we use what we call a data source
that we do it in these specific blocks
that then get translated to JSON.
And then, like, because I need
to create the edge override,
which is the way I'm telling
Cloud WAN between two regions,
what is the region I want to use?
What I did is define that logic outside
of the policy document definition,
kind of like creating a variable
and then just creating dynamically
that those blocks here.
So if I need to do any changes,
I don't need to go to the
definition of the policy document.
I can go to my variable,
local variable, do the change,
and then anytime I deploy
again the policy document,
I will get that updated.
So now let me continue
with the next block,
because we did from prod to dev and hybrid
and we missed dev to hybrid.
And now the last thing I need to do
is the attachment policy.
So I already have one attachment policy
which is getting the tag
value of the attachment,
and if the tag is inspection equal true,
that means that it's an inspection VPC
because the inspection VPCs
I have already connected to Cloud WAN.
And now I'm going to do two
more attachment policies,
one based on the tag
and another one based on
the type of attachment.
So give me a moment
that I finish that piece
- [Claudia] Of course.
So what you can see here is that basically
AWS Cloud WAN works with segments.
These segments can be across regions.
And we are having dev
segment, prod segment,
and the security segment
with AWS Network Firewall.
Yeah.
- [Audience Member] If you
were to automate this in GenAI,
what tool would you use?
I mean Amazon Q can do this
or Kiro also has-
- [Claudia] Yeah, the question in here is
how to automate this
even more using GenAI.
And yup, you can work with Kiro
or you can work with Amazon Q Developer.
Remember the Amazon Q
Developer advise you, like,
the next slide to write.
It works also with AWS Cloud, mm-hmm.
Yeah.
So the other thing that we
are really excited with Pablo,
it's that we just got announced
a couple of weeks ago,
I don't know if somebody saw it,
that we are now having advanced
routing with AWS Cloud WAN.
Advanced routing, it's a
new function where, like,
you know, like, adding many routes,
like, 100 routes, 1,000 routes,
like, every day of the network engineers.
So the idea with advanced routing is
you can add now filters.
You can now, like, inbound
filter, outbound filter,
you can summarize route,
you can use BGP attributes, BGP metrics.
So you can add that.
So this can just to
make easier the routing
and your route tables.
So it's freshly baked,
so if you start implementing AWS Cloud WAN
also can take advantage
of this new feature.
So back to you, Pablo.
- [Pablo] Yeah, so we have already created
the new version of the policy document.
Let me go to the console so I
can show you how that works.
So this is the AWS Network Manager console
where Cloud WAN lives.
If you have transit cases,
you can also take advantage
of these Network Manager capabilities
by just importing the transit cases.
But in Cloud WAN, it works natively.
So you see that my policy
version, it's the 15th.
So we did a lot of dry
runs before this session.
That I have two different kind of aliases
when I'm doing some changes.
I have my live policy,
which is the one that
is currently deployed,
the one without notice attachment,
the attachment policies,
the service insertion,
routing, and everything.
And then the new version,
which is the one we have just created.
That is going to take some time to deploy
and once its it's deployed,
it will move to the live version of it.
It will take some time,
so of course, like, maybe it's
time for some questions or...
And also maybe we can
move to the next section
if it takes longer,
because usually it can take longer
if it's adding new region,
removing region can take some minutes.
Now that we are just
creating some routing,
maybe it doesn't take that much.
And also you see that
what I have already created are my three
inspection VPCs attached
to the network function
group inspection VPC.
So that piece is already there.
So now we can just create
those specific routing.
So it's already been deploying everything
so it's telling you which actions apply.
The attachment policies are
just applied automatically now.
It's going to be creating
all the static routes.
Do we have any questions?
- [Claudia] Yes, I just have one in here,
and that is if someone has
permissions in the account level,
can they, like, bypass the
service control policy,
and the answer, it's no.
- [Pablo] Yeah.
- [Claudia] Service control
policy will always be up
or over the account level
permission that you have.
- [Pablo] Yeah, exactly.
And there was a question over there?
- [Audience Member] So
you defined where all the,
what regions are your inspection VPCs,
what they look like,
and did you also tell it
whether you're inspecting
on both the source and destination region
or just one of them?
Is that part of it?
- [Pablo] Can you repeat that?
I didn't hear the question.
- [Claudia] If you are
inspecting both source
and destination region-
- [Pablo] Yes.
So in service insertion, when you say,
so let me come back to the definition.
So when you say where I have it here,
like, dev to hybrid also is hybrid to dev.
So it's bidirectional when you do it.
So it's going to be between
source and destination, yeah.
- [Audience Member]
Right, but if you're going
from us-east-1 to us-east-2
and you want to inspect (indistinct).
- [Pablo] Yeah, so now
that's where I define that,
for example, between us-east-1
and eu-south-2, so Spain,
I'm saying that I only want
inspecting US in North Virginia.
I can say by defining here dual hop
that I want to be inspecting
in the two, in both.
But in that case we're doing single hop
for the sake of the example.
Cool.
Then while we create AWS Cloud WAN,
I think we can move to
the third requirement,
and then, of course,
we have everything connected together.
Okay, so what have we created so far?
So basically we have all this.
We have the inspection
between routing domains,
we have the egress inspection,
we have the cross-region and
the attachment automation.
Do you think that we have
met all these requirements
or are we missing anything?
- [Claudia] I think we're
missing something, Pablo.
- [Pablo] Hmm?
(audience member speaking off mic)
Yes, so thing is I, we can do it.
So we can meet that one easily
by just simply saying to everyone,
hey, put your OU tag
when you connect your VPC
or doing in the account factoring
that we mentioned before,
doing it by default that
they don't need to do it.
But what if someone puts the
wrong value of the tag domain?
They may be connecting to hybrid.
They may be connecting to prod.
So still we need for our
use case or requirement of,
I want to make sure that new
VPCs go to the right segment
and the way we define the policy document,
we need a little bit of extra help to make
that requirement to be met.
And that's how we're going
to enforce routing domains
from OU using, again,
AWS Organizations and AWS Step Functions.
So as we did with the VPCs,
we're going to create another
service control policy
for the spoke OU
and the spoke accounts
that they won't be able
to create the tag domain.
It will be created from
the networking account.
So they can create any
tags in the attachment,
but not the tag domain
because that's the one that defines
in which segment they're connecting
and we want to do it from
the networking accounts.
Once we do that, that's
going to be denied,
so they're going to be
creating the attachment
to nowhere in Cloud WAN.
So it's just an attachment
without any association.
And now what we're doing is
as part of Network Manager,
we have the capability
to get events from changes in the network.
AWS Network Manager events
are sent to EventBridge.
I'm showing there Oregon,
and why I'm showing Oregon,
because the home region of AWS Cloud WAN
where their control
plane resides is Oregon,
so all the metrics
and the events are going to
be populated into that region.
So our even breach is going
to catch those events.
We are going to filter
by only new VPC attachments.
I don't want to get much
events, only those ones.
And I'm going to send
it to a Step Functions
to do this logic.
Wait for the VPC attachment creation.
That most likely is just, like,
a measure to make sure that
we don't start doing the logic
before the attachment is created.
I'm going to obtain the OU
information from the account ID
because that's metadata
that I get from the event
and I'm going to create the tag
from the networking account.
So we will see how after
the attachment is created,
it changes from no segment
to the segment we want to be connecting.
So that's what we're
going to do right now.
- [Claudia] Perfect.
So we had a question back there,
and I'm going to move now for that one,
that the thing in here is just
we are using AWS Cloud WAN
to deploy the network,
but service control policy is the one
that is helping us from someone
to not deploying the things
that we don't want as,
Pablo and I, as the network
specialists, to be deployed.
So yeah, as you saw the beginning,
there was only IPAM and
service control policies.
There were no AWS Cloud
WAN just to show you that
you cannot, like, bypass
service control policy
or deploy other IP addresses
that are not allowed.
But it's not because our IPAM
or AWS Cloud WAN is for
service control policies.
And I think we had
another question in here.
What was the question?
- [Audience Member] Yeah, the testing.
- [Claudia] Okay, can you repeat that?
- [Audience Member] Yes.
So once we create the new
policy for Cloud WAN, right,
it's generated and we see, you know,
we have a latest one and
we have a current one.
Is there a way to test connectivity
before finally applying it
and if it fails to go to previous version?
- [Pablo] So currently we
don't have that option.
So you can, of course, when
you create the new policy,
you can check what is
changing before you...
From Terraform or CloudFormation,
it will do the approval automatically
to not break the infrastructure
as code way of working.
But if you do it from the console,
you can, of course, check what it's doing
and see if there's any destroy action.
Currently we don't have the
way to test that before live.
What we have created
recently is cloud on MCP
that kind of helps you
with different tools,
how to quickly check if
the routing is happening
once you have it in live,
that policy document.
And then, of course,
you can always roll back
to previous options if you don't, so...
(audience member speaking off mic)
Yeah, so you can use
Reachability Analyzer-
(audience member speaking off mic)
Yeah, yeah, so we are, exactly,
so those tools are the ones used,
but then you need the
coordinator policy already live.
So we're, of course, working to ways,
because feedback is also, like,
I may want to check this
before I have it created,
so we're working on that,
but for now it needs to be live.
Then, of course, use tools
to understand if the
network is properly defined,
but if not, you can quickly roll back
to the previous version
of the policy via API
or via the console and then
continue with your deployment.
So let me go quick to the
service control policy
that I'm going to let create
while I'm explaining everything.
So what I'm doing is
I'm denying the creation
of any VPC attachment
if there's this domain,
there's this domain key,
and of course, denying
any tag modification.
So I'm not allowing anyone
to change the domain
tag once it's created.
So I'm doing that at the dev OU level.
And now I'm going to be
building the automation.
I'm going to cheating
on the automation side
because I have almost
created, I just, I'm going to,
it's coded, I'm just going to uncomment it
and we can discuss it
while it's getting built.
So I'm creating this from
the networking account.
Okay, so the automation, it's
what we mentioned before,
the even bridge rule
that is capturing only VPC attachments
and capturing the Network Manager events,
but only the ones who are
VPC attachment created.
That's the only thing
that's important right now.
And I'm sending this to Step Functions
and to see exactly what I'm creating.
A step function is always better
to check it from the console.
You have a better UI.
And yes, if I go to my state
machine, to the definition,
so it's here.
Let me make it bigger.
That's what we are doing.
So we are getting the VPC attachment
just to first check if
the attachment is created.
Majority of the times is
going to be created already,
just kind of like a safety measure.
And then I'm obtaining
the organizational unit
from the account ID,
getting the domain from that OU.
So in that case we're making it simpler
because the OU name is the name
of the segment in Cloud WAN.
But here this step is maybe
if you have extra logic that,
okay, OU means non-prod,
to add an extra logic in the step.
And then we're creating
the tag in Cloud WAN.
So basically our three,
four steps that allows us
to get this extra logic
into AWS Cloud WAN.
So yeah, so with that, perfect.
So with that we have built these
or we have built those requirements
applying the best practices
that we mentioned before, no?
So with AWS Organizations,
what we are doing is
not putting the efforts
on blocking actions that
they shouldn't happen
at the network level by just
simply, like, denying actions
or putting a firewall when we need to
or just to thinking that, okay,
I don't trust anyone so I
will kind of own everything.
Now what we're doing is creating
those guardrails in
organizations so it's okay,
no one is going to put a CIDR block
that it shouldn't be or it can be...
No one is going to put in
their VPC in that gateway,
so I don't need to just freak out if...
Or not allowing them
to do specific actions.
I know that they cannot
put in that gateway.
So yeah, go free and work with your VPC
because it's your workload,
so you should also work with
your own network for that.
Then with Cloud WAN,
we built a global network
in three AWS regions
with less than 50 lines of code, no?
So we will see later how VPCs
will automatically connect
and the routing will be
created automatically.
And then finally, we had a step function.
So we had this ad hoc requirement
that we needed to build some
automation in top of that
and then we used five states to ensure
that VPCs are only being associated
to their corresponding segment.
So now let's go and try it out.
We're going to finish the
definition of our three VPCs.
We have a data center.
Well, it's A VPC in Paris
that is going to mimic a data center.
And we are going to do a VPN
and we're going to see
how the site-to-site VPN
is going to get connected
directly in the hybrid segment
and our spokes VPCs are
going to first create
a node-to-node segment
and then our automation
is going to kick in
and move them to the routing domain.
And then we're going to show
how the automation works
and get some more
and show you more about the
configuration on Cloud WAN
before we finish the session.
So yeah, so let me come
back to the coding piece.
- [Claudia] Yeah, so in here you can see
that we have been working
mostly with Amazon VPCs,
but AWS Cloud WAN can
work with Amazon VPCs,
AWS site-to-site VPN, AWS Direct Connect.
It can peer with AWS Transit Gateway,
also with AWS Transit Gateway Connect
that it's the solution
to work with SD-WAN.
So in here is that you can
work with AWS Cloud WAN
not only with Amazon VPC,
but also to help you deploying the routing
and everything that you need
for the hybrid connections
that it's pretty usual
for many of our customers.
- [Pablo] Yeah, so right
now what I'm doing is,
as part of the VPC module,
the way to create the core
network attachment is to define,
okay, this is my core
network that was created
and that's why I have a local variable
because I'm checking that ID
or that ARN from AWS RAM,
and here I'm putting just the routes.
So basically I'm sending any IPv4 traffic
or any IPv6 traffic to the
core network attachments.
And the last thing I need to
do is to create the subnet
where I'm going to be
placing that attachment,
and I'm making it dual stack
by assigning an IPv6 block.
And this is just part of the
configuration in the module.
Just we're saying that it
doesn't require any acceptance
because in Cloud WAN you can
also put some controls about
do I want to accept the attachment
before it automatically
connects to a segment or not?
So I can add some manual value.
In our case we didn't want to.
That's why we built the
automation to control that.
But if you don't want to
build that automation,
you can add some manual control
and just simply get notified
when you have a new VPC
to check it and maybe to
approve the association.
I'm cheating a little bit
because I have already my private module
just to create EC2 instances
and some endpoints to connect to.
I don't think we will have time today
to show end-to-end connectivity,
but just in case we have the time,
we are building some EC2 instances.
So now I'm going to do the same
in the rest of the environment.
Yeah. Any questions?
Okay.
Perfect.
Okay, so that's on the spoke account.
I already have everything.
Let's make sure that
I did not mess up something.
- [Audience Member] Hey, is it possible
to set up custom error messages for SCPs?
- [Pablo] Yeah, I did some.
I did... I know... Let me check.
- [Claudia] Like, for the user?
- [Audience Member] Yeah,
because we've avoided
using SCPs for, like, tag enforcement
out of fear that internal customers
won't understand why they're-
- [Pablo] I'm just doing a split,
so I need to take the second item,
which is the ID from the ARN.
That's what I'm doing in
this specific section.
So now it should give me everything.
What was the question there, Claudia?
- [Claudia] Yeah, we have the
question that if we can send
a message to customers that
they're getting blocked
by service control policy
because they usually don't understand why
they're getting blocked when
they try to do something
that service control
policy is not allowing
because it was configured that way.
- [Pablo] I don't know.
Maybe I will need to...
I have not, don't know if
that's possible or not.
Maybe we can take that later
and then do a little bit of
quick research if it's possible
or get you to the right
person to answer that.
But I don't know.
I don't know.
And then the last one
is on the on-prem side,
I have already created the VPN.
So I have my customer
gateway, my VPN connection,
and the only thing I'm
going to be creating
is the site-to-site VPN attachments.
So now once I create it,
I can move and show how
everything has been created
and just see how the different
automation is working
and how everything is getting
connected to Cloud WAN.
So let's, it's on the networking side,
so it's not creating anything?
Oh no, I need to be in
the on-prem mode, sorry.
So the on-prem, so the VPN,
even though I have
another Terraform estate,
I'm working kind of independently
for the on-prem side,
it's getting built in the
networking account that...
And this is why the
site-to-site VPN attachment
needs to be created,
the attachment, maybe, on
the VPN needs to be created
in the same account
where Cloud WAN resides.
That's kind of the same way it
works on the Transit Gateway.
So let's go to our console to
see that now we have our VPN
and the VPN already is getting associated
to the hybrid segment
thanks to the 300 policy
attachment policy configuration,
which is the one we can show
in now from the console.
So you can see how all
the logic and everything.
And now the VPCs,
for now they're just being
created without any segment.
We will come back to them,
to the attachments tab in a
moment to see how they moved.
Look at, for example, the one
in Spain already got created
and it's moving already
to the dev segment.
So now it's just pending
the network update
of the association
and the propagation in
that specific segment.
So before that, let's go
and check the policy version
and then we see kind of
how everything is working.
So even though we did that data source,
Cloud WAN works with JSON.
So what we did
or what it was already
created was the ASN ranges.
So (indistinct) in
Cloud WAN is using EBGP,
so we need to provide the range of ASNs
that we want in the regions,
then the edge locations in which regions
we want to create Cloud WAN.
So in that case, three regions only.
And then we have the attachment policies.
I already explained
this when we were doing
that part of the code.
But then the logic for the VPCs was,
hey, if the attachment type is a VPC
and also the tag domain exists.
I did a typo here.
This should have been an end.
We can even update it later in a moment.
If these two conditions are met,
I want you to put you in the two, like,
I want to put you in the
segment that has the same name
as the value of the tag domain.
So with this attachment policy,
I'm covering all the possible
use cases for my VPCs
if I do that logic of OU name segment
or your own logic that you
want to do in Cloud WAN.
And then the last one is,
hey, if any of these
attachments are connected,
so any site-to-site VPN connect attachment
or dark connect gateway,
I want you to put it in the hybrid segment
so I make sure that
anything that is hybrid
goes to that routing domain.
And then I configure my
network function group
for my inspection VPCs
and my three segments,
dev, hybrid, and prod.
We didn't use prod today,
but it's just to show you
as an example of how you can
create different
segmentation in Cloud WAN.
And then lastly, we have
the segment actions,
as we were mentioning before.
Now we have routing policies
to get you to more
advanced routing controls.
So filtering, summarization,
advanced BGP capabilities
like changing the as path,
changing the local pref
or changing BGP communities.
But in that case we're showing you
how you can insert firewalls.
So basically we have the send to action.
It creates a static route
pointing to kind of a default
for egress traffic to the inspection.
But then we also have the single hop,
the send via between
the different segments.
And here you see that even
though in my policy document
I created the dynamic block,
when it translated to JSON,
it creates the override.
So basically between these two regions,
I want to use the first one
and then everything that we
define in the local variable.
And then we have it both
for prod to dev and hybrid
and then from dev to hybrid
so we cover all the different use cases.
Now let's go to attachments.
How much time do we have?
Okay, we have some time so we're good.
So you see now that the three
VPCs already moved to dev,
so let's go to our state
machine to see how,
why that happened.
So we see three executions.
So it was our three VPCs moving already
to getting created.
So getting the notification to even breach
and coming to step function.
So let's pick one as an example
to show you what happened.
So here what I did is
obtaining the VPC attachment,
and I was obtaining three things,
three variables in Step Functions.
First of all, the AWS account,
basically from the input
getting the attachment ARM
and I'm getting the account
where the VPC was created,
the attachment ARM
and then the attachment ID.
First choices state that,
just checking that from here
I'm getting the VPC attachment.
So I'm also obtaining the status
of the VPC attachment if it's available.
So if it's created,
I just move to the next
state that I'm getting,
the organizational unit.
So from the account ID,
I'm getting the organizational unit,
and in the other one I'm getting the name
of the organizational unit.
And the only thing I'm doing
now is tagging that attachment.
So doing the cool thing
in Step Functions is
I don't need to be lambdas, like,
Step Functions provide native integration
to majority of the AWS APIs,
so I'm just directly calling
the APIs for those services.
I'm tagging the attachment
with the dev domain equals dev.
So if I come to my VPCs,
I see that the type is
already there in domain dev.
And the cool thing is that if
now I am in the spoke account
and if I go to Cloud WAN
and I check my attachment
because that was created
in the spoke account,
so it is shared with me.
So here I have it.
I see my...
I don't see the coordinator,
but I see the attachments
that I created for the coordinator
that they share with me.
I can also see those tags.
Something cool because for
the ones you know, like,
when you do AWS RAM,
the tags are not shared between accounts,
but Cloud WAN is sharing those tags
between accounts so you can
see and potentially control,
unless we block it as we did it today.
You can also check the
tags of that attachment
so you understand better why
my attachment was connected
to the segment.
But also, for example, because
it's a shared resource,
I don't know what I'm connected to.
I'm just simply connected to Cloud WAN
and I trust my networking team
to have built all the routing for me.
Okay, so I think with that,
we can start closing it up.
First, like-
- [Claudia] Yes.
So yeah, there is a repo.
You can start working with AWS Cloud WAN
Service Control Policy.
Everything is AWS sample
is the official reposit
where you can find these
and many other solutions,
and also you can start
working with AWS Cloud WAN
specifically with guidance for attachment.
- [Pablo] Before you move,
so in the Cloud WAN blueprints,
we already moved to version one,
and you have even examples
for these advanced routing
with routing policies.
Feel free to check it,
create issues, create PRs.
We're really happy to get
at least these blueprints
where we can interact with you
and you can tell us,
okay, I want to see
that specific use case.
The guidance solution,
it's basically the same idea that we saw
with the Step Functions,
but for production real environments
or thinking on production
real environments.
So it helps you to create this extra logic
in the attachment management of Cloud WAN
if you want to add those extra controls
aside the attachment policy.
And then, of course,
some examples on service control policies.
Yeah, sorry.
- [Claudia] Don't worry.
And then we have also AWS Skill Builder.
This is the platform where you can find
many different courses
for free, some of them,
and other one needs to be paid.
And yes, we have specifically for network
and content delivery.
You can find in here
more about AWS Cloud WAN
and other networking services.
- [Pablo] As I said at the
beginning of the session today,
some key takeaways.
You can forget everything
that we said so far.
This is the important piece.
So the first one is architect
by use case, not by habit.
So what we have seen so
far in customers is, like,
as they're growing,
they are just putting one specific service
because that's where they
found in the documentation
or that's where they're comfortable with
or their partner is comfortable with,
and then everything needs to operate
around this architecture decision.
We see success doing the opposite.
What's your use case?
That's why we're here.
Tell us your use case
and we can help you define
which is the best service
for your specific use case.
And then, of course,
like, the idea is, like,
you don't have one service for everything.
I know that it's, of course, like,
you need to be in the middle, like,
not like, hey, yeah, let's
use all the portfolio
of AWS networking to do connectivity.
But for sure it's not only one.
Like, we need to get, like,
define properly the use cases
and make sure that we
have the right pattern
for the use case.
And for that we need to
start with business outcomes
and then architectural agility.
So understand where we want to get,
where we want the business to...
When and where they
want to reach that goal
and then architect for agility.
Infrastructures called modular designs,
continuous iteration.
Most likely you have really
well-defined pipelines
and automation in your applications.
Take those learnings
and put it also in your infrastructure
so you can also have that iteration.
And services like Cloud WAN helps you
to not have to control
big infrastructure as code
files with so many resources.
You have everything in one single place.
And then orchestrate beyond networking.
We see that not only
networking is the key,
service control policies,
organizational security measures,
automation, take full control
of the portfolio of AWS also
to build the infrastructure that you want
to get your business quick
and to the goals that
you have been setting up.
So with that, thank you very much.